my Guardians don't forget this might be
dangerous let's put on our mean faces
what happened
Oh wipers
get it off of this dude still alive he's
not a dude you're a dude yes this is a
man my hands off lost you are mad it's
like as mussels are made of cotati metal
fibers stop massaging his muscles
[Music]
who are you guys
everybody is Charlie brand-new infinity
war footage right after some dropped
earlier this morning is crazy
put on your mean faces I love that
basically the scene where Thor meets the
guardians of the galaxy so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
that's going on you know I've got some
crazy news about the Deadpool TV series
that I'll explain at the end of the
video but basically what you have here
like you can kind of judge the timeline
based on the trailers we've seen so far
Thanos boards the Asgardian ship at the
end of Thor Ragnarok takes the space
stone from Loki kills most of the people
on that ship like people say they can
see Heimdall sword underneath the legs
here that could be true we don't really
know what happens to Heimdall we know
that Valkyries supposed to survive
because I think they're using her later
in the franchise for other things even
though she's not like a really huge
infinity war character but also Hulk
turning into the Hulk from that clip
that I posted earlier today him getting
booted to the sanctum but Thor basically
just gets chucked into outer space like
you see tano's squeezing his head like a
grape like he's about ready to burst the
thing about the guardians though is that
they're mostly a comedy franchise like
they mostly play for laugh so like you
have Drax oh look it's a man a muscular
man is that even Gamora gets in on the
action the reason why they're playing
this moment so much for comedy though is
because it's coming right after that OHS
kills all those people on the ass
guardianship so they kind of want to
balance the WTF out with the laughs so
you have fan oohs just doing the
craziest things but then you have the
guardians characters like rocket that
just sort of provide commentary on
what's going on like okay things aren't
so dire like there are actually some
heroes out here that can help out but it
sounds like what's happening is is Thor
because he's still in Asgard space they
didn't travel that far from Asgard when
Thanos his ship rolled up is that the
guardians are probably trying to track
fan OHS down because of something else
we don't really know what throws them
onto his scent because we haven't seen
too much of them in the trailers just a
little bit they go back to nowhere to
check in on the collector because they
took the Power Stone their children
about it and he can probably give him
some information I don't know whether or
not he knows that they have the reality
so maybe Thor tells them that oh we sent
it to him but then they sort of split
that group because all the Thor scenes
that we've seen so far in the trailers
of him forging his new Stormbreaker
weapon even though they've hilariously
omitted it from all the CGT see this is
a clip without the lightning you see him
holding his fist up in the air curled
around nothing that's how good they are
with the trailers like just click delete
Photoshop or remove the only people so
far that I know travel around with them
is just teenage Groot or adolescent
Groot in rocket maybe Peter Dinklage
shows up there's a rumor that he's
playing the king of the dorbz so that
would be the storyline where he would
pop up but this sort of confirms that
all this stuff that happens with Loki
Thor on that ship happens before the
Guardians scene really early in the film
and there's also a rumor circulating
that Thanos will already have the power
gem when the movie picks up so like
we're not gonna get a big long Zander
scene where he just rips through all the
Nova Corps to take the Power Stone maybe
that's why the guardians are after him
like they hear about that so when we
first see them they've already learned
about that and they've been tracking him
down but let me know what you guys think
of this so far and some of the jokes
that they put in these trailers they've
been a couple funny moments for the most
part it's been pretty WTF though I'm
Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man spider-man being one of the
other comedy based characters obviously
he's gonna be used a lot for that like
oh my god this is so amazing even though
things are blowing up all around them
the really crazy news that drop while I
was waiting for this footage though is
that FX networks and Marvel have decided
to pass on the Deadpool animated TV
series that means that they're basically
canceling it before it ever starts there
was gonna be 10 episodes total it was
gonna air on FXX and it was basically
donald glover and his brother the people
that make the Atlanta TV show we're
gonna make the Deadpool a TV show based
on the pitch it sounds like it was going
to be kind of like a Rick and Morty
adult animation show where it was
basically Deadpool commenting on
everything going across the Marvel
Universe just doing all the things you
would expect that character to do your
time's up you dumb [ __ ] well that's just
lazy writing but just get a load of the
statement that the network released so
it says due to creative differences
FX Donald Glover Stephen Glover who's
his brother that was producing it with
them in Marvel television have agreed to
part ways on Marvel's Deadpool animated
series FX will no longer be involved
with the project FX and Marvel
have an ongoing relationship through our
partnership on Legion that Legion TV
show which is getting ready to start
which will continue I'll explain what
all that means in a second but it also
goes on to say that Floyd County the
animation house behind FX's archer
series was on board to handle the
animation production for the Deadpool
project now that doesn't mean that the
Deadpool series was gonna look like the
archer series it was just gonna be the
same studio I assumed that they were
gonna have very distinct styles of
animation but then it reads on although
the show had been targeted for debut
this year the series was not in active
production nor is it believed that any
of the scripts had been delivered which
you can't start animating until you
deliver the scripts animation takes
about a year to complete so they're
claiming creative differences so what
might have happened was a Star Wars Han
Solo situation where they fired those
directors because the movie that they
were turning in that they were actually
making was so off-brand for Star Wars
that it didn't feel like a Star Wars
movie and it really freaked the
Lucasfilm people out like holy crap that
might be the same thing that was
happening with the Deadpool scripts
because Donald Glover actually made some
statements last year where he was
talking about the difference between his
work on Star Wars because he's in the
Han Solo movie and they were actually
working on the scripts for that series
while they were shooting Han Solo in the
way he was talking about it made it
sound like he wasn't sticking super on
book with Deadpool like when you hear
people are doing a comic book series but
it's not gonna do anything from the
comics or the way they're writing it
isn't true to the characters like a lot
of times people will do projects and
they'll be like you know we're doing our
versions of these characters but you
can't really do that with big characters
like Deadpool like Deadpool acts and
does certain things for very good
reasons you screwed up Deadpool is a
character is a walking ATM machine so
whatever it was the Donald Glover and
his team were turning in it probably
freaked the [ __ ] out of Marvel and FX
out so they're like you know what we
just we can't do this it's gonna be too
bad you know either people were gonna be
too upset about what it was gonna look
like or who knows I don't want to
speculate too much but a lot of times
you get really good creative people they
just think that they can do awesome
versions of the character without being
true to their comic book origins or just
way too off-book so as for what they
might do with this going forward who
knows but I'll probably do a follow-up
video in a couple days but just let me
know what you think about this would you
rather than do a Deadpool series even if
it didn't feel like movie Deadpool or
comic-book Deadpool or are you happy
that they pulled the plug on this before
they could do something like that so
what will happen is is I'm working on a
Dragon Ball super series finale video
that'll post either early tomorrow
morning or later tonight just depending
on how fast I get through it while you
wait for everything click here for that
other big infinity war trailer video and
click here for that new Deadpool trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]